وحش غير مرئي ينطلق
عبر الفضاء
ولا يبدو خطيرًا على الإطلاق، وهذا
ما تسميه وكالة ناسا الآن
ثقبًا أسودًا هاربًا محتملًا يراه
تلسكوب هابل الآن على الرغم من أنه
غير مرئي توم فورمان من سي إن إن مع
التفاصيل هنا توم
ما الذي يحدث، نعم جمعة سعيدة
أخبار جيدة، جمعة مباركة،
هذه ظاهرة غير عادية
يقول علماء ناسا إنهم لم يروها
من قبل وبالطبع الجميع
متحمس جدًا لهذا، ما تنظرون إليه
هنا هو تصوير فني
لما يحدث على اليسار
في الأسفل  الزاوية هي هذا
الثقب الأسود العملاق الهائل الذي
ينفجر عبر الفضاء
بسرعة غير عادية، ما تراه في
أقصى اليمين، المساحة الضوئية الصغيرة في الأعلى
هناك نوع من اندماج الضوء
الذي يبدو أنه مرتبط بما تراه
في المنتصف والذي  هي النجوم التي يتم
إنشاؤها عن طريق ضغط الغاز
أمام هذا الثقب الأسود لأنه
يتحرك بسرعة كبيرة، وعندما يأتي الغاز
حول الجانب الخلفي ويتم تسخينه
يشكل النجوم بشكل طبيعي، كان من الممكن أن
يلتهمهم جميعًا ولكن ضعه  في نوع
من المصطلحات الفيزيائية البسيطة التي ستكون
غير صحيحة تمامًا ولكني سأعطيك
فكرة إذا أخذت مكنسة كهربائية
ودهست سجادة قذرة حقًا، فسوف
يمتص كل شيء إذا قمت بذلك
بسرعة كبيرة فسوف يمتص بعض الشيء  ستؤدي الأمور
أيضًا إلى خلق فوضى مع كل شيء
آخر، لذلك يعد هذا اكتشافًا مثيرًا حقًا
ومذهلًا جدًا يا جون، لقد
قيل لي بشكل موثوق أنني أسمي هذا الثقب الأسود بوقاحة، لقد
أسميته فائق الكتلة
ولكن تم إخباري أنه يزن 200 زائد
الوقت  هل هي 200 شمس 20 مليون شمس 20
مليون شمس وزنها 20 مليون
شمس ورأيت 20 مليون شمس رأيت
فيلم الثقب الأسود عام 1979 وما
زلت خائفًا، فلماذا لا يكون هذا مخيفًا
جيدًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء، هذا مفيد  قم
بالقياس لأن لدينا جميعًا إحساسًا حقيقيًا بمدى
وزن الشمس، لذلك من
السهل حقًا الحصول على 20 مليونًا منها، ولكن ولكن
هذا الشيء يزن كثيرًا
ويسافر بسرعة كبيرة ويمكنه الانتقال من
الأرض إلى القمر في حوالي 14 دقيقة  تبلغ
المسافة من القمر حوالي ربع
مليون ميل، وهذا أعلى بكثير من
الحد الأقصى للسرعة، والشيء
المثير للاهتمام حقًا في هذا هو أنهم وجدوه
بالصدفة، وكان جون ينظر إلى
صور من تلسكوب هابل الفضائي
وعندما كانوا ينظرون إليها
لاحظوا  هذا الخط الغريب الصغير في
الفضاء، اعتقدوا في البداية أن
هذا كان مجرد قطعة أثرية
على الكاميرا وليس الحالة، وبدلاً من ذلك
وجدوا ظاهرة لم نشهدها
من قبل